Guy Peter congratulations you guys are
in the forged and fire final when you
showed up here we asked you to use our
Forge our tools and Machinery to create
a signature weapon of your own design
now we're going to send you back to your
home Forge where we're asking you to
create an iconic weapon from history
the Elizabethan Rapier the Rapier
originated in Italy and Spain and then
gained popularity throughout Western
Europe though they varied in size and
shape after the 1500s the word Rapier
came to refer exclusively to the Slender
thrusting sword we now know nearly all
of the blades are rigid narrow but come
thinner toward the point and have a
complex Hilt to provide protection for
the hand wielding it
they were developed as a weapon for
urban self-defense and private dueling
their weight was concentrated in their
hilts making for a fast single-hand
stabbing sword with a Long Reach that
could be used in the street back alley
or an enclosed space
whether it's wielded by Inigo Montoya in
The Princess Bride or the Three
Musketeers the Rapier is easily one of
the most recognizable blades in film and
literature we'll see you in five days
good luck
I'm guy Harris I was an art major in
school and Blake smithing has a lot of
that in it you're sculpting a piece of
Steel into something meaningful I worked
for a company that produced rapiers I
made parts for rapiers I've assembled
the rapiers but I've never done all of
it from start to finish it's very
important to try and keep it straight
[Music]
this thing's a beast roughly 48 inches
of Steel I'm getting ready to do the
Heat Treating I'm not sure exactly what
I'm going to get out of it I'm a little
concerned about it
the blade actually heat treated solid
and it's pretty damn straight that's
looking really good I made an elliptical
shaped guard so you have a reference in
your grip you always know where The
Cutting Edge is
it was going to be it's Far Far and Away
simpler than the previous guard
that's the balance I'm delighted it's
done
my name is Peter Martin I was a hunter
back in the 80s the factory knives were
not the best and I decided to take on
knife making as a full-time career I
don't have the equipment for this thing
I'm gonna have to do something different
I'm setting up these two ovens back to
back but soared's longer than both of
them things put together first thing
this morning I'm going to quench the
blade into a cylindrical tube of oil
that's 60 inches long
many problems can happen in the quench
the biggest thing is that the cracks
cross your fingers that it doesn't
self-destruct
well I didn't hear it Go ping so that's
really a good thing so when they go ping
you can just pretty much drop it in the
oil tank it's over with
the blade has to be final finished and
sharpened I still have floating to do on
the handle gonna try to incorporate this
as the butt cap there's still plenty to
do and not a lot of time to do it
things all dented
that sucks gentlemen to test the
sharpness of your tip I will run it
across this ballistic bag and then
thrusting it let's see how sharp your
tip is guy you're up first you ready
ready
let's do this
it does have a good slicing ability and
thrust capability
with this particular grip which makes it
more difficult to control the weapon
because of the length
but
it will slice
all right Peter you're up next are you
ready
as ready as I'll ever be
let's do this
[Music]
well Peter
it's very heavy
I could not grip it properly to get a
good recovery it is sharp it will thrust
but I cannot properly deliver multiple
strikes with it
to kill test for this I will hand you
over to Dave who's an expert on European
weapons
gentlemen in my opinion the Elizabethan
Rapier is one of the most elegant
weapons ever created
this is not a battlefield weapon this
weapon was designed for civilian use and
everything about it was dialed in for
the duel
to test your weapons we've got these
ballistic gel dummies we put them in a
doublet to simulate the clothing of the
period
guy you're up first you ready yep all
right
let's see what damage we did
the shot to the belly
went in about eight to ten inches
kind of went a little high there took
him right in the chin that would have
gone right into his mouth right into the
brain
so all in all to uh
quote a friend of mine it will kill
so Peter you ready sure
but let's open it up see how we did
all right well you can see that shot to
the belly just went right in
I actually think I hit the spine on that
one
there's an exit wound back here that was
sticking right through
it'll definitely kill
next is the strength test now what made
the Rapier possible were advances in
Metallurgy making for a longer thinner
stronger blade that had a good stiff
spine but enough flexibility that it
wouldn't break
what we're going to do is we're going to
place your blade tip down in this rack
and flex it to 35 degrees in One
Direction 35 degrees in the other
direction make sure that temper is right
and that that blade doesn't pick up a
set in either way
there are 10
20
30 going all the way to 35
. it's right at the peg
all right going the other direction
10.
20.
there's 30.
all the way
35
didn't pick up a set
didn't break
nicely tempered
thank you
so Peter you ready
you're ready as I'll ever be okay
ten
twenty
that's 30.
go into the peg
35.
here we go in the other direction
10.
20.
30
going to 35.
right to the peg
well the blade stayed true
nicely tempered
thank God sigh of relief huh absolutely
I'm very nervous very anxious I feel
that there's a good possibility I may be
eliminated in this final challenge uh
due to the weight Factor I'm
apprehensive about the entire thing
gentlemen through three rounds of
competition you've both worked
incredibly hard to produce some
outstanding work
but in this competition there can only
be one winner of ten thousand dollars
guy
you are the forged and fire Champion
congratulations
Pete you did not make the cut well Pete
overall you made a beautiful piece but
big issue was over balance in the front
of the blade making it very tip heavy
because of the stretch in the handle and
that heavy weight there those are the
reasons we had to cut you loose
understood Pete please surrender your
weapon
guy congratulations you are the forged
and fire champion and you'll be
receiving a check for ten thousand
dollars how do you feel uh pretty damn
good we did a beautiful job on that
blade a big thing for me is
functionality you're fit up with solid
your sword was solid and just performed
better in the tests I'm totally stunned
it's great it's really cool
[Music]